this little rabbit of mine it's been
continually today escaping this
extremely generous enclosure that I've
built for her sorry in eye on this one
what's up guys my name is the channel
welcome why do I keep doing that intro
it's every time I face a camera it's
like hey what's up guys my name is the
channel welcome I want to live that life
anymore you know what's up you guys I
thought that I would make a little bit
of a vlog today just feeling it you know
it's a Saturday morning my wife's at
work I'm all here alone by myself and I
figured it would be a good opportunity
to kind of share a little bit of what
I've been working on with you because
I'm so excited about it I really want to
start getting into doing these kind of
chill videos a lot more and if I don't
have been doing stuff like this on
patreon for quite some time now but I
want to kind of bring it to YouTube I
guess now that I've let's just say
practiced on the patrons because that's
what I seem to do a lot of I hope that
you guys doing okay in the kind of state
of the world right now I know that a lot
of people are struggling with so many
things and you yet I mean it absolutely
sucks everything that's going on I'm not
gonna try and like downplay that or
anything but I also don't really want to
talk about it too much because I want
hand I think that a lot of people
talking about it and also I don't know I
just feel like I just don't want to like
capitalize off of this horrible
situation that's going on with the world
right now but what I did want to do
today is actually take a look at some of
the questions that you guys ask me
because do you remember a few videos
back I get 200,000 subscribers and I
said that kind of as a celebration type
deal for that I was going to make a
video I was gonna make a Q&A video this
exposure just changing every like five
seconds so I asked you guys for
questions on both that video and also on
Instagram and I think I got like 300
questions on each platform so I'm gonna
see if I can go back on Instagram
just see some these questions I am gonna
make a Q&A video but I just thought it
would be nice to maybe dream these kind
of vlogs that I do just chance or a
couple questions or something like that
so that we wouldn't have to wait like a
year until I finally get the chance to
make that video okay here we go I found
it and there's yeah there's so much so
many questions here so I don't really
let's just pick one randomly I'm just
gonna put my finger down this one knows
about okay this one why did you start
making YouTube videos this is by Daigo
PB PG s I'll put it up on the screen
while I start making YouTube videos
there's an excellent question
it's a long story and maybe something
that I'll save for a future video but I
will give a short answer here so I've
been kind of involved with media for a
long time in general ever since probably
2006 I want to say even I was maybe 11
years old
I really liked filming stuff on my
camera I had my parents had like a
little handy cam and me and my friends
would always like mess around with it
and try and make like you know action
films and that kind of stuff I'm sure a
lot of people have a very similar
childhood that grew up with cameras in
the house but eventually got to the
point where I decided that I wanted to
become a filmmaker that was my career
journey I wanted to be like a film like
I think producer or director of
photography specifically and I think I
was pretty much in my final year of high
school when I decided that you know what
I also know I not only like being
creative and love making content and art
and all of that stuff I also really like
maths and I also really like technical
things and so I decided that I'm gonna
try and learn programming because I want
to be able to like I was rendering I was
doing a lot of visual effects for movies
that I was making these little films
that I made and you know I was making 3d
models doing 3d renderings putting them
into After Effects compositing
everything I was doing all of that stuff
all
that was like my life in my final year
of classical in the year before I think
as well and so I got to the point where
I was like well you know what why don't
I try and build a renderer like abyss so
that I can actually render all of these
3d graphics myself instead of using like
did you guys hear that she did it I
cannot believe this how did she it has
to be that gap it has to be that gap you
what is wrong with you why do you always
feel the need to get out of this little
amazing enclosure that I've built you
huh seriously what do you have to say
for yourself I can't we're back so what
was I saying
seriously I completely forgot so it was
around then that I decided that I kind
of wanted to go at creating these
renderers myself I wanted to be able to
like find out what all the algorithms
are what all of the technical code is to
build something that can create images
and create 3d renderings of things now
back then I just completely had no idea
how to write card I'd never written code
in my life maybe I had done some kind of
HTML or something for like I take class
but I had never programmed I was about
16 and never written any code in my life
so I decided that I would start learning
programming now back then minecraft was
really big notch was doing all these
live streams he was using Java and me as
a 16 year old looking at this game that
I love playing with my friends and it
was written in Java I was like okay I'm
gonna learn Java and also because a lot
of people were always saying that our
job is you know pretty easy to learn C++
is this hard language it's used by
professional companies sorry this is so
bright it's used by all these
professional companies Java is really
nice and simple you know start with that
and so I did and about half a year into
that I decided that you know what I'm
gonna start making videos of myself this
kind of learning journey of mine of how
I'm kind of learning all these 3d
graphics all of this kind of cool stuff
in Java and all of this stuff I'm gonna
start making videos of that I'm gonna
show people what I
nor because at that point is well in
high school I was you know helping
people with maths every now and then
like just people would come up to me
like hey like you know let's work on
this problem together and as I would
explain to them how to solve this
mathematical equation I realized that
hang on a minute this makes a lot more
sense to me now because it's not you
know I because I've had to explain it to
this person and taking that in mind I
started making videos because I thought
that well if I kind of try and teach
this stuff I'm gonna have to obviously
do a lot of research on it I'm gonna
have to understand this really well so
that I can communicate that to others
and that's basically why I started
making videos now since then of course
it's been I don't know my very first
videos on that topic were probably 2011
and then I like on a different Channel
and then like eventually I started this
channel and it just kind of you know
went on and it's it's been a while
things have changed a lot I didn't even
notice their boss boss when I started
this channel but then of course I
started going to university I decided to
not become a filmmaker I decided to not
study film and I decided to instead
become a software engineer because
that's what I really wanted to do and
you know fast-forward like eight years
of my life later I decided that a mix of
birth is probably where I like to be I
really like art I really like filmmaking
I really like making videos but then I
also need to like I really like
programming and I really like building
things and I guess the happy medium that
I've stumbled upon is programming art so
in other words programming like graphics
and 3d rendering and all that stuff and
game engines so that is how we are here
today the other thing that I really want
to show you guys is be kind of well I'm
I was gonna show you my office but
that's gonna be a very terrible idea
because it looks like an absolute
junkyard right now but here we are
what my desk looks like right now all
I'm gonna do here is I really wanted to
put this down so we're so off we're
trying to put this somewhere especially
if things are in the way what I want to
do here today is show you guys a little
bit about the stuff that I've been
working on this week for hazel so if
those of you don't know there's kind of
two versions of hazel there's the public
version of hazel which I constantly
develop as part of the game engine
series but then there's also my version
of hazel which is called hazel dev and
hazel dev is something that patrons have
access to it's like a repository of code
that we have like 3d rendering in and
it's all of that stuff and this past
week in fact these past two weeks
I've been doing live streams I've tried
to do I've done one a week so far and
I'm maybe will do more patreon
conference - the channel is where I do
all of these live streams if you're
interested in showing your support and
also getting access to the live streams
then the link will be in the description
below but basically I'm just streaming
myself working on everything is
completely you know raw it's just hours
of me trying to solve problems and
figure out all of this stuff so the
stuff that I've actually worked on the
stuff that I've implemented into hazel
these past two weeks have essentially
revolved around environment maps so we
had a fairly kind of basic way of
dealing with environments and
environment maps which are very
important to something called image
based lighting which is like a rendering
thing that's you know usually used with
physically based rendering it basically
means that you can sample the
environment around you to try and figure
out the color of an object that you're
trying to render because obviously the
environment affects everything that is
in it if I have like literally have
nothing useful around if I have this
candle here then you know if my walls
are green this candle is gonna appear
slightly green because you know the
light bounces off the wall hits the
light hits the candle and then you get
your green color so to simulate that we
basically have these environment maps
these cube maps inside a game engine
that basically is used to try and render
an object with those with the influence
of that light color so previously in
hazel we were doing there
using just like an 8 bit like cubemap
that had to be generated in an offline
tool and then important hazel there was
this huge kind of pain thing that I
didn't like at all and so we switched to
using these equirectangular or lat/long
that sometimes called kind of image maps
of HDR environments we can now import
those right into hazel it will like run
some computers and figure out everything
it needs to to actually put them into
the bucket to convert them into a cube
map to filter that cube map to create
something called an irradiance texture
it does all of that stuff for you and we
get a fairly beautiful image let's take
a look so to show you guys what I mean
this is basically how hazel
used to work for all of our IPL maps or
our environment maps we had to basically
create this cube map that is an 8-bit
texture if you look up here you can see
it's an 8-bit texture you can see looks
fairly contrasted because we've had to
kind of squeeze all of that HD arnis
into an 8-bit kind of texture format so
it looks pretty crunchy this was called
our radiance map we also use an offline
tool called CM ft studio to generate an
irradiance map this would be also used
for IBL so we have these two maps which
we've had to kind of manually generate
from a texture that was in an air
correct angular format which I'll show
you in a minute now this has a lot of
downsides and another huge problem with
this is that we only had one mill of
this we just had this full resolution
texture and for physically based
rendering to model different roughness
models is really important that you have
a good kind of map chain of properly
filtered MIPS because we basically have
to down sample this texture - you know
all across the map chain but we were
just using OpenGL for that we just said
GL gen mid Maps and it created all the
map maps and this is that was kind of
like a very basic kind of rough and
so-to-speak way of just getting this to
work as quickly as possible but what we
actually wanted to do was use a proper
kind of filtering algorithm to actually
filter it properly all across the map
chain and also generate an irradiance
texture so what we actually do now is we
take in something like this which is an
aqua rectangular environment map and you
can see here that it's a dot HDR file
and it's a 32-bit image so what we were
kind of doing before was just basically
taking this and converting it into an
8-bit image like this now by doing that
you know we lose detail because
you can see here that this is massively
overexposed but if we bring that down
everything else seems kind of dark and
we kind of had this issue of but you
know what do I pick I can't possibly fit
all of the detail that is within this
image into an 8-bit format in fact you
can't even see this you can see this is
completely blown out white but if I go
in here and start to bring down that
exposure you can see that we recover all
of the detail there so the solution
really is to actually load an HDR
texture inside your engine and then the
engine can decide what the exposure
should be a lot of games do this by
using something called adaptive exposure
where they just basically look at what
the pixels are the camera is looking at
and then they try and determine an
exposure level much like auto exposure
on a camera so we can do that because we
have this HDR texture pipeline so now
what happens is you can just load this
texture this one image this one HDR
image into hazel and it will
automatically run some computers to
generate a cube map that looks like this
along with a properly filtered map shine
using on one of Unreal Engine 4
algorithms which they released in a
paper and then also generate this
irradiance map all that happens on the
fly in about half a second on my
computer just by dropping in this image
so let's take a look at what that looks
like so here I've just opened hazelnut
which is kind of the editor for hazel
let me just scale up this gun because
the units were using here are meters and
obviously guns are quite small so this
is what we have kind of by default by
loading this gun model with this
animation let me just stop this
animation because it's kind of gonna get
annoying I just had this basic control
here we can stop the animation but about
to start okay so what you see in the
background is the environment map it's
just being rendered as a skybox and we
can actually control which lot or which
MIT level is being rendered by just
using this control here so you can see I
can kind of bring it all the way to
maximum sharpness here which is just the
kind of the first map mm number 0 and
then I can gradually kind of bring that
into well very extreme low maps which is
basically just a solid color as you can
see here this is just controlling the
background and what we see in the
background now you'll see that this is
very overexposed but that's okay because
we can bring down this exposure and you
can see that we get all of that detail
back because it is in fact an HDR map
let's bring that back a little bit
so we have our gun here and you can see
that it has a roughness here of 0.2 so
if I kind of go into here you can see
that it's slightly blurred but the
blurring looks really nice and that's
kind of the point if I bring it all the
way to zero roughness which basically
makes it look like a mirror you can see
it's quite sharp and then as I increase
the roughness it really gradually and
beautifully I think blurs out which is
really cool and then eventually where
the roughness of zero means is basically
not reflecting anything all you can see
is kind of the contribution of the light
of the environment to the kind of light
that light that hits the surface of this
model and the same works for plastics as
well if I bring the metalness to zero
you can see that we kind of have a very
glossy reflective plastic versus a very
rough plastic here and in fact I think
all of these reflections are going to
look a little bit more impressive if we
learn a normal map so I'll go over here
and I'll load the normal map for this
gun and enable it okay so now you can
see we have a lot more detail and we
kind of have this really cool looking
kind of noisy I guess reflection because
of the rough surface of this gun and I
can obviously still control the
roughness as much as I want here and you
can see that it does in fact look pretty
nice let's play that animation again and
we have a nice gun that of course
because of the environment map because
of the fact that we're using image based
lighting it really does look like it's
part of the scene we can also load the
albedo texture which might make it look
a little bit more realistic here and of
course there's also a medalist and
roughness texture which I could lard but
I'll just kind of leave this off here
but just so that we can look at the nice
reflections that we have here and of
course the cool thing here is that I can
drop any environment map I want into
this and it will just work so if I go to
HDRI Haven for example which is one of
my favorite resources for these
environment maps if I go to HDR eyes
these are already used you can see
they've got plenty of categories here if
we go to like sunrise sunset you can see
all of these different images here what
I can do is I can simply download one
that I think looks nice so let's maybe
find a nice-looking one let's go with
this one maybe pink sunrise so we can
download this in a variety of
resolutions I'm just gonna click 4k that
should be good enough for us it's going
to download the file here so I've got
the file over here now I'll copy the
path to this file go back to Hazel I'll
click a lawyer environment map I'll
navigate through that
and I'll just open it and you can see
that it's now loaded the environment map
our scene looks completely different we
now have this pink sunrise that we
downloaded from the internet takes like
half a second to load we can now
visualize this with a new environment
map you can see it looks really nice I
can of course increase the exposure to
make it a little bit more visible but
you can see it does in fact blow out the
sky but if I bring that exposure back
you can see all that detail comes back
which is super nice and we now have this
beautiful kind of night scene with this
gun that definitely looks like it's part
of the same so yeah I'm pretty excited
about that just wanted to kind of show
you guys where hazel dev was at and keep
you updated with the development of
hazel one of my like biggest plans and
gets goals for this year and what I
really want to do with hazel del
specifically and with this kind of 3d
version of hazel is actually create a 3d
scene just from scratch and then have
that rendered in hazel and maybe make
kind of like a cool atmospheric
environment that you can walk around in
and experience with maybe like some cool
sound design and everything that will
make it just very atmospheric I guess
like really like an experience that you
can like do it you know sit down put
your headphones on darken the room and
just experience and the kind of
aesthetic that I'm leaning towards
creating at the moment is some sort of
like Soviet you know post apocalypse
like environment something like stalker
or metro that kind of I guess feel
that's what I'm kind of going for now I
haven't started working on this scene
yet but that is the plan so I'll
probably take you guys along with me on
that little journey and keep doing these
kind of vlogs and talking about all of
that let me know what you guys think of
that idea please let me know if you've
enjoyed this video hit the like button
if you did and of course if you want to
help support the channel and catch all
these live streams were actually
developed the hazel engine then patreon
Oakland for dr. Turner was the best way
to support me and I just want to give a
huge thank you obviously to everyone who
does help me support - that does help
support me in this time because I know
that is it's very challenging for
everyone and it kind of sucks that we're
going through all of this but I just
want to thank you from the bottom of my
heart everyone obviously not just people
who just support me on patreon but all
of you people who watch my videos
because that's the reason why I'm
sitting here in front of you and I just
I love you all
stay safe everyone
I'll see you next time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]